now you had sent over a couple of photos
yeah all right I gotta be honest with
you about the photos that you sent
okay
I just feel like it's not the right
representation of you
number one there's a lot of photos with
filters
[Music]
how would you feel if I showed you a
picture of a guy and he looks so young
and then when you see him he's got right
okay so I kind of need you to give me
some photos that are more authentic to
who you look okay
I sent her some great photos yes they
had some filters on it I mean it's still
me
you know I didn't really know what she
was looking for at the time so I just
kind of sent her the best ones that I
had in my phone at the time
but I'm totally fine taking more
pictures with you know all natural
tell me about your family like your
upbringing okay
um I'm a twin and
um you know we had an older brother so
it was just three of us with my mom and
dad okay they got divorced around when I
was 12.
um my dad's a businessman we was always
kind of looked up to him like wow he's
got such an exciting life but
he was busy a lot he was he was wasn't
home a lot
dad got married two other times
um and then divorced those two other
times so
um oh
my parents got divorced when we were 12.
and I don't really feel like I had a
good example to see and know what a
healthy relationship looks like
my mom she never got remarried
she never really dated much after the
divorce my dad even though he's had
multiple marriages they were
not long lasting I'm sure it affected
you know both Stacy and I
and now I just feel like
I don't want to be like my mom
lonely
she's a little league
daddy too
sometimes we I think we just choose the
wrong ones because we don't have a
little bit
and figure it out that's why I feel like
Anita
talk to Michelle and try to figure
things out for myself so I don't
you know
dialogue
[Music]